The client interacts with the rest of this pattern
through an abstract interface.
For example, if your application provides the end-user a way of
drawing diagrams, then the abstract interface might have the name Graphic.
If you were modeling an organization and
its employees, you might use the term Unit.
To indicate the general nature of the pattern, GoF uses the term component.
In the diagram you can see that the client class talks to the component class,
and that the component class is abstract because its name is in italics.
The component class has a variety of operations as well as the ability to add
and remove children and access any of the children of the component that exists.